leute was geht ab hier sein herz
bekommen zu diesem video ich mache ich
nur diese kleine ansage in der ich euch
zuerst einmal vielen vielen dank für
300.000 abonnenten sagen wollte richtig
cool auf jeden fall vielen dank dafür
aber das eigentliche video besteht aus
einem kleinen best of video zu sagen
dass wir zusammen mal so ein bisschen in
erinnerungen schwelgen können was die
letzten monate passiert ist auf jeden
fall vielen dank an euch dass ihr meine
videos schaut dass wir nicht sofort und
einfach am start seit das feierlich auf
jeden fall ja dann würde ich sagen jetzt
viel spaß mit dem video mit dem best auf
und bis zum nächsten mal nachts gut
luca der bremse verbannt
er ist auch im herbst gewesen nicht sein
herz alter okay die laufen grad beide in
die mitte die anderen alle beide täter
hinein
ich habe gegessen habe außerdem dem
mausrad des räubers ca
ich werde jetzt meine ersten meter auf
diese schulen fahren und ich werde es
heute noch ich werde heute noch
hinkriegen dass sie mit den teilen
fahren freunde ich bin das erste mal
gefahren fahren fragt könntest du dir
vorstellen kontrakte zu heiraten
er steckte fisches geschützt ja das war
meine freunde
und ich kann ja eigentlich einfach
sprechen sondern kann einfach ohne
probleme dieses flugzeug in die bertram
weil ich ja um sieg fahren
ein schönes auto wurde schreibt einfach
in die kommentare was ihr euch jetzt
denkt nachdem wir das ständige gesehen
haben wie groß ist dein penis trikots
träumen was vor allen dingen ich bin die
ganze zeit nur stocken und dann drop ich
einfach zum job von weiter her hat
schreibt man die kommentare was ihr zu
wissen so zum beispiel die große zu
entgehen
herr kollege
jung geworden und wird zusätzlich passte
irgendwie nicht so kleinen es war sehr
locker nicht überlebt bis heute überlebt
wie unter die runde gestellt es wäre
jetzt der absolute wahnsinn männer das
überlebt hat aber dann dann hätten wir
ja oder ja
junge junge junge junge junge befinden
da ist das ding geht works 30 herzen
wirst du wirst du ja hier oder damals
gelang max an herzlich zu einer runde
gestern zusammen mit stewart nun mit mir
kann ich mit problemen schon wieder weg
nicht und ich kann ihn nicht wussten
fänden posten als lag ein bisschen ok
haubner ist schonmal separiert ich habe
mir keine hitze hier ich kann ja ein
treffen haben wir acht oder nicht